so the president has described as xi
Jinping as a personal friend and praised
much of China's action in response to
kovat 19 at least early on so what's his
take on this latest Chinese strategy do
you believe that China is inflicting
this upon our country no I don't believe
they're inflicting I think they could
have given us a lot earlier notice
absolutely because I see that they're
very high you know if you look I'm 95
percent of the Republican Party it's
been very combative in the press
briefings a lot to unpack there with the
ranking member of the House Intelligence
Committee California Congressman Devin
Nunez joins us live-- good to have you
with us sir great to be with you Shannon
okay let's start by talking about China
in the new york times into the headline
it's coronavirus cases dwindling China
turns focus outward about now how
they're reaching out to other countries
it says with new daily cases at home
dwindling into the single digits
China is mounting a diplomatic offensive
to help and aid blitz that is giving
China the chance to reposition itself
not as the authoritarian incubator of a
pandemic but as a responsible global
leader at a moment of worldwide crisis
congressman is that gonna fly I don't
think so House Republicans on the
Intelligence Committee have had a
long-running investigation into China
and what you're beginning to see is what
we've been seeing for many years and
that is is that this is an authoritarian
regime that cannot be trusted one of the
most important things that we need right
now out of China Chanin is it would be
nice to have good data about how they
tested what were the symptoms what were
the different age groups and and what
were the symptoms that they came up with
what were the best treatments these are
all things that you're not seeing which
you are seen as secretary Pompeo said as
you're seeing them blame the US Army
that's unacceptable
this virus originated in China they
covered it up and they have caused a
worldwide panic okay tonight earlier on
Tucker I believe it was Senator Tom
cotton talked about introducing
legislation to break the u.s. dependence
on pharmaceuticals that china is now
dangling over
heads at least rhetorically where do you
think that goes mm-hmm well look I think
that what you're gonna see after we
after we figure out how to treat the
this virus and hopefully it begins to
slow globally what you're going to see
as many countries that are gonna for
sure want to break the supply chain that
we're not going to want to have to rely
on China for anything that is that is
paramount for the survival of our people
or for our or to our economy and so you
know we had already started that with
some of the trade sanctions that we had
put in place and the Train trade tariffs
that the Trump administration was
dealing with now I think people are
beginning to understand that it's not
just about the supply chains it's not
just about their 2025 and 2035 plan that
they have to rule the world
you also have other issues out there
Shannon like how they're subsidizing
Huawei and they're trying to roll out
the next generation of communications
capabilities and also how they're
stealing us blind with from with our
intellectual property these are all
issues that have to stop I think you're
going to see major pieces of legislation
that are going to begin to move and
ultimately become law to rein in a a
wild and out-of-control authoritarian
regime in China okay
dr. deborah birx said today that we're
changing our projections our ideas every
single day because we're getting so much
new data in with that in mind I want to
take you back to Sunday night when you
said that folks should go out and try to
patronize local businesses in ways that
they could there has now been a very
strict crackdown from the federal level
on down on all kinds of things bars and
restaurants closed everywhere I want to
give you a chance to answer your critics
who've said you got that totally wrong
yeah that's a total fake news once again
what I said still remains the case it is
still true right now what we have on the
ground here I'm out in California the
number one problem we have right now is
we have hundreds and hundreds of people
that are going into Costco and grocery
stores and other places that's exactly
what we don't want you to do in the
meantime we have restaurants that
remaining open that can serve food
safely and cheaply they're moving to
take out you have drive-throughs so once
again this is you know the fake news
making this very political and it shows
what little credibility they have they
have no clue it's fun to to get drunk
and sit in your ivory tower in the swamp
and Washington DC and send out tweets
it's another thing when you go out and
get on the ground out here in California
and you see hundreds of people in line
waiting in line in the cold and the wet
in the rain trying to get old people
young people all sorts of ages this is
not good and right now we actually do
have we have restaurants that are open
people can go and get food yeah it's
just as you know in DC right now it's
just pickup would you say to people
though not to go places where there are
dining rooms or open areas are you
strictly saying you can pick up but
don't go to places we're gonna sit down
and be next to people well I think most
of the restaurants now would prefer you
not to dine in that what the what most
folks have been recommending is is that
you want to keep spacing away and you
don't want to be in larger groups of ten
I think that's the best way to think
about this is just be smart just try to
practice social distancing which is not
what's happening at Costco and Target
and grocery stores right now and you
know the media you know had they
actually taken to heart what I said on
Sunday and actually told people in this
country that we do not have a food
shortage and please stay out of the
grocery stores stop hoarding things and
go to the local restaurants where you
can get where you can get safe and warm
food we'd be a hell of a lot better off
right I want to ask you really quickly
because they're two members one
Republican one Democrat not that that
should matter at all right now but this
is now a bipartisan impact for people on
the hill have tested positive will you
get tested well I don't know if I'll be
tested because I think we need to make
sure that the tests are available for
those who really need them I did just
speak to Mario diaz-balart
who's a close friend of mine he's
recovering well he said that
he had some you know high fever over the
weekend sharp headache has a cough but
feels pretty good and wanted everyone to
know that that you know a lot of people
can get over this and I still think the
the the number one issue that we have
out there right now shannon is that if
you have a respiratory issue at any age
you need to be very very careful and and
Mario diaz-balart
had actually self quarantined himself
because he has family members that have
respiratory issues and think Phyllida
that he was he stayed away from his
family because he knew he was around a
lot of people and he knew getting close
to someone that had a respiratory issue
could be problematic and he made the
right choice for spam we all need to
follow those guidelines and today the
Surgeon General said ninety nine point
three percent of people will recover we
got to share that message as well
congressman Nunez thanks for making time
for us good to see you my pleasure thank
you